hmm so you're pitching the show yeah are
you getting meetings with networks yeah
why do you think that is why is they
[ __ ] it's got a line they don't [ __ ]
with waste their time you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but you know how it because
you I think you're the same type of
personality because when we first did
this show you were like I'm not getting
[ __ ] and mean when I come to find out
you're gonna be on an NBC ABC or only
that's great though
are you feeling good about that no no
you like can I just say this okay is I
don't know if you know this about me but
I'm a recovering alcoholic all right
why'd you laugh at that because I know
it oh you do yeah yeah I'm a recovering
alcoholic yeah and I went to an a
meeting today uh-huh
that one oh and I spoke at it I hear now
you're bragging I'm not bragging I'm
just gonna say there was that offer only
who booked it Michaels Malorne look make
him if he's [ __ ] leave this medium
then make him give it this opening pitch
I I literally when I was doing this me
at this meeting I go this is what was
missing from from my life I think as of
late it made me feel like because there
was like this sick kid that was in the
audience like you know the audience but
in the room and I talked to him
afterwards
and he was just like you really helped
me out like you know oh yeah you know
and you just to me it's like well yeah
it's being so expensive I think that
that's my real ultimate purpose if there
is a god that that would be my purpose
to help my fellow man and it made me
feel like for the first time that felt
better than me getting that show to be
honest we just gotta get out of yourself
that's like that's true it's such a
burden off of you know it off your
shoulders when you just remove yourself
from yourself that's the key to life I
really is to get out of yourself and
baby that's the [ __ ] greatest thing
I've ever heard you say
you really have to get out of yourself
it is very true because I go around all
day
why didn't I get this and what the [ __ ]
and then seeing a billboard in this town
[Laughter]
get a boy yeah by the store it's really
hard like driving like a low all that
look at all the glow it's yeah and then
when I went up to Marc Maron last week
and I go congratulations like he's not
doing it what is that about cause it's
it's like we always are are like feeling
like now I'm not doing that but I'm
gonna say some message to the people
listening right now and this is pure and
this is real nothing will fix you [ __ ] I
know but listen no matter what you get
and I'm telling you because you're you
know no matter what you get what job you
get it for a second you're like oh I can
you know oh I see what you're saying
you're still left with yourself
interesting right I always think big
money's gonna thing you do I think it's
gonna fix a lot of things yeah my leg
I'm at the age where people like ah [ __ ]
it doesn't it doesn't but you know
people go out [ __ ] okay I know I
know like I've gotten you know big guest
star parts or whatever odds on sitcoms
like Mulaney show yeah that that [ __ ]
got cancelled right away no I cancel out
I feel like I'm on a lot of shows if you
you don't have that kind of power
yeah I know but I've put some shows to
bed anyway I was cooler who's the guest
star this week it's a pepper town he's
playing the dirty uncle [ __ ]
why what's the matter Ted no it's just
that I worked on a want to show with him
in the studio burnt down that day he was
on it
[Music]